Speaker 1: Let's start now with some
of the kind of last gasps of obvious
2020 election delusion. I'm going to talk to
you about the term decertification now some of
you will already know where this is going in the
United States. One states certify an election.
There is no legal provision to then
decertify that election. And even if a state.
Figured out some way to decertify an
election if Arizona now said, Hey,
we're decertifying our election from November
of 2022. It still wouldn't remove the sitting
president of the United States. You'd need
to remove the sitting president, you know,
either through invoking the 25th Amendment and the
process that goes there or through impeachment.
And even if you did that, the vice president would
assume the position. So there is no such thing as
decertification in the way that some people
have been claiming it exists. MyPillow CEO
Mike Lindell, known to us as Mike Pillow, he is
still talking about election decertification and
in fact, he appeared yesterday on the Stephen
Bannon show called The War Room. Stephen Bannon
is a former Trump adviser, former Breitbart
propagandist, and he has been hosting Pillow
for a while now. And Pillow's new thing is he
now has elected officials supporting multiple
certifications. It's happening imminently, guys.
Imminently, this is going to happen. Take a look
at this and ask yourself the question Does Pillow
believe this or is he just giving fodder to the
last people that still believe this stuff?
Speaker 3: Well, Arizona, you know, that
was a water bottle over a week ago, and now they
are. They've got quite a few representatives and
senators that signed on. We're
getting more and more every day.
I was in Wisconsin and all they need there. We
I was over there with a great TIM ramp, and here
he is. The senator that put the bill before
to has it ready to decertify Wisconsin.
Speaker 1: No, he doesn't pillow.
Speaker 3: It was an amazing event. I was there
for five hours. I plan on being there for a half
hour, but there's much concern there all over us.
Speaker 1: The lies were so
compelling he stayed five hours.
Speaker 3: If we go here, we have the evidence.
Let's get this decertified. I met some other
senators and representatives, Steve, they're
they're this close to getting on board.
I believe we can get them all to jump on together
because there are a lot of them still live in
fear. They're going, you know, fear or they're
not. They were very, very. A lot of entrants just
to be educated on this, that a lot of them said,
Well, there's nothing that can be done anyway.
Absolutely. There can be done that. We build
lawyers, constitutional lawyers. Look at this.
Three of these states, you decertified.
And then it goes back to all the states and
and a bunch one person or one state,
one vote. And it's Republican control.
Speaker 1: That is a complete and total lie.
I mean, understand that this isn't aside from
whether there is the willingness to do this, aside
from whether there's the interest of doing this,
aside from whether there's any empirical
evidentiary support for to put all of that aside,
even if it happened, it doesn't go back
to where each state gets to cast one
vote about who becomes president of the
United States. It's just it's a fantasy.
Speaker 3: So this is very real and it's come
it's manifesting now. It's coming to fruition
and it's going to happen, Steve.
Speaker 1: Now understand that Pillow
has made an entire sequence of predictions. In
November of 2020, he said by December, it would
be flipped to Trump. In December, he said that in
time for January 6th, it would be flipped to Trump
on January seventh or eighth, he said. By the
time of the inauguration, I will be flip to Trump
after that, he said, March, April. Then it got
pushed to the summer, then the end of summer.
Then in August, he said it would be by October.
And then he said it's going to be by Thanksgiving
and then it's going to be by the end of the year.
And it's 2022, guys, and it's not happening now.
We are almost at the next election.
We're almost at the midterms.
Everything that he says in this clip about what
could happen and how things would happen is a lie.
I don't know whether Pillow even believes this
stuff. I highly doubt Bannon believes this stuff.
And the idea here is Wisconsin and Arizona will
decertify the winds of Joe Biden 15 16 months ago.
Now, to take it seriously for a second. This has
been studied. There is no legal basis to decertify
a US presidential election. There is no provision
in the Constitution to decertify a presidential
election to remove a sitting president. You need
they die. OK, then goes to the VP. You have the
invocation of the 25th Amendment. If a president
is unable to discharge the powers of office,
you have a conviction on impeachment. You have
a resignation. OK, in all of these situations.
The vice president becomes the president. You
don't go to a candidate who lost 15 months ago.
Constitutional experts have talked about we've now
talked about the Electoral Count Act many times,
and it provides the process for certifying. Buying
the presidential election, it doesn't have a
provision for decertification, and it's almost
like these guys like pillow and others think
anything, any process that exists can be run in
reverse. So it's almost like hitting a rewind
button on a VCR. It's not true. And even
if a state were to undo its certification,
it would have no legal significance whatsoever.
So these these people are in a fantasy world. I
don't know whether they believe it. Maybe
you have some kind of sense. All right.